camila cabello and shawn mendes's
relationship is officially over and now
a source is telling e.t why the singers
decided to call it quits we're really
supportive of each other we're told the
split was mutual our source explaining
that the couple quote realized they are
in totally different places in their
lives at this point and it was time to
end things and although sean and camila
are both sad about going their separate
ways the source adds the two are quote
doing their best to take care of
themselves stay busy and surround
themselves by loved ones i'm lucky i
have awesome people in my life the
singers announced the news of their
breakup on instagram wednesday here's
the joint statement they both shared
which reads in part quote we've decided
to end our romantic relationship but our
love for one another as humans is
stronger than ever we started our
relationship as best friends and we'll
continue to be best friends we so
appreciate your support from the
beginning and moving forward she's been
one of my best friends since i was like
15 years old the duo split comes two
years after they started dating their
relationship began in july of 2019 and
they even moved in together during the
covet 19 pandemic
e.t spoke with the stitches singer in
2020 and he confirmed they'd discussed
an engagement but weren't in any rush i
know we're really young so i don't want
to jump like insanely fast but
i think when you find your person you
feel and you know that you found your
person
this year sean and camilla celebrated
their two-year anniversary with a
romantic caribbean getaway
and more recently the couple looked
happy hitting the met gala red carpet
together that same month sean also
turned up at the premiere of camila's
movie cinderella to support his leading
lady and when e.t caught up with the
havana singer in august she opened up
about having shawn nearby on set didn't
he surprise you for your birthday yeah
he did he said
the week of the ball and he saw me do
one of those themes yeah um he saw me do
the scene with the gong like where i
fall or whatever oh yeah um yeah and so
yeah he was he was he was there for the
whole beginning of it and
was so supportive
[Music]